oh
i just want to do a quick update
people a little bit of time to get in
here so
we got our models training today across
32 gpus we got a melanoc switch
an sb uh
7800
gpu direct rdma potentially
the switch has sharp uh
you know you can uh so it can do
hierarchical reduces inside of the
switch
allegedly if your nickel is the right
version we should update our nickel
well if we update our nickel i bet it'll
get faster but it's already
mad fast um
i'm streaming
wanna say hi no you want to say hi
not in the mood oh hi uh yeah so much
parallel right so actually you guys
aren't looking at the parallel right now
so here i am ssh into four machines
gpu seven nine
eight and five don't ask where six went
this is the model it's converging tons
faster than the old model not only these
epochs happening faster
yeah look we're already at negative 2.5
losses
and if we go over here to the model that
was trained on a single computer if we
want to get over to negative 2.5 losses
man we got a scroll for a while
it's like here it's at epoch 102.
here we're only at epoch 30.
um no i'm good uh so it's blazingly fast
um we're going to take you on a quick
data center uh sorry not a data center
we we have a not a data center it's
definitely not a data center
uh we're going to show it off to you
guys right here live in this stream
you know why i do these streams we're
shilling we're looking to hire
new people for the research team if you
want to come here
it's about a three-year push
probably now to uh sell self-driving
cars maybe it's less maybe it's less
all the pieces are coming together um
we all should have seen the writing on
the wall with value prediction networks
that was a 2017 era paper there's a new
one there was one from jan lacoon at
iclear
last year and then of course there was
mu0 at the end of last year
and mu zero uh dynamics models
are the key to solving self-driving cars
we just need to put it all together we
have the data sets required
uh we have the gpu power required
we just need a bit of code
written and debugged and uh
in some ways we're kind of in the home
stretch it's a long home stretch
but uh all the pieces are are finally in
place
so let's go over to the data center
um you know for the for the haters
who are like oh comma comma you know you
know it's not it's all fake man it's not
fake look at that money
look at that money does that money look
fake to you that's 323 thousand dollars
in 30 days we're rich uh
so yeah calm is profitable you guys know
that look at all this trash look
look at all these comma twos ready to
ship
buy yours today these are ones with
cosmetic defects
waiting to be fixed these are all the
ones that are ready to ship
um yeah but let's go into the nada data
center
all right so it's loud as hell in here
mostly because of that switch oh it's so
loud
look at these beautiful things look at
that
this is to prevent the dust from getting
into them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this it is so
scaldingly hot back here you guys
wouldn't believe how hot it is look at
all that
ethernet interconnectedness
oh look at the switches blinking lights
here's our brand new melanox switch
[Music]
wow yeah that's our data center
look at our racks and racks
[Applause]
of 3d printers we got racks on racks
on racks that's what the rappers were
talking about they're talking about
racks look at these racks
whoa crazy amount this switch is so
loud and we got more machines over here
[Music]
yeah the cloud boys the clouds
oh that's our data center here's
our big array of harnesses look at all
the different kinds of harnesses you can
buy
look at all of them get your harness
today we have one for your car
it doesn't matter what it is unless it's
a ford then we don't have it but
it's one of those cars we have it here
all the things that fail qa
a surprising amount here's our big qa
board you guys seen this full of comma
twos look at that money boys look at
that money
all right uh yeah we have a vw harness i
think
uh oh these are gonna these going in the
computers
they're new back planes got a bunch more
computers there and guess what
is over here even
more computers these are going to be the
new ssd computers we're scaling
everything up
get ready for some really big models
we have a micro intern coming tomorrow
for the research team which like i said
we're expanding
the research team fast because we're in
the home stretch boys
we're gonna sell self-driving cars you
know it's been
five years we're gonna finish the
project
like it's what it is what we build uh
it's alphago it's really just alphago
tiny twist
uh you need to ensure two things uh you
don't have a uh you can't use a dynamics
model
that you're hand coded like alphago so
you got to use it like museum you got to
learn it
um and then you got to ensure that it
stays on the map and doesn't go off
policy
but there's great tricks for that it's
just a question of implementing all this
stuff and building it
we have a beautiful vision vector
feature space that's actually what i'm
training right here
um this is a vision model which reduces
the driving down to a 2048 dimensional
feature vector
um with one line i can scale this up
this is running an efficient net b2
but uh we can run b4s on the comma two
so you guys are gonna be getting a b4
uh we gotta make big model we gotta
scale the box up
uh but this is all
coming soon this is this is this is the
home
uh stretch i get i mean it's not you
know
it's all coming together about that
uh our goal is to solve level three in
three years
don't ever said i said some unrealistic
[ __ ] i did not uh
but yeah we think level three within
three years is actually achievable
um the definition of level three that
we're using
is every time the car is going to make a
mistake which it may still make mistakes
but it knows it in advance
um the problem's not hardware you know i
always say that level three in three
years
three years the photo coloring project
the photo coloring project is doing
so well oh it's doing so well
um let's go over to come
ai uh hang on just in case there's
secrets
can't show off any secrets yeah check
out
common 10k it's coming along so well
they've almost labeled
5000 images and give me a second i'll
bring up some stuff to show you uh
you think i don't know how to stick
another camera on something
when it's time for the next camera it's
time for the next camera
we're still using like none of the
camera that's on there
the problem is not hardware get your
lidar companies acquired by scam specs
for 3.4 billion dollars
it's all the wrong way of thinking about
it
doesn't help if you can't solve the
problem of one camera
you can't solve self-driving cars
i tell you what the solution is deep
learning big deep learning
alpha alpha go alpha zero mu zero
got to take it a little bit further
because we don't have a reward
function you got to deal with that how
do you deal with that stay in the map
right drive like a human right stay in
the map i think that's actually the only
reward function you might need
um so yeah check out check out the yan
lagoon paper i talked about it a few
times ago
what do you need for level five the same
thing just more of it
um right here i can show you what that
uh
what concretely
what the uh new labeling is doing
so we have train train three
here we go
so this is this is my uh trainer for the
segnet
i'll just bring it up here uh
i get this okay
um let me let me i gotta zoom this to
match okay
that's not even close to matching wow
okay nevermind it doesn't match but look
at this so
this is epoch
260 with only 3000 images labeled
and then once we've got 5000 images
labeled look at epoch 260 there
the val set and the uh law set are
alright the valset and the trades that
are on top of each other
um what we saying about how it can
invert data
uh yeah so if you guys want to join
before the big take off um
now's the time tesla is not at level
three
no nobody is at level three
uh the deep learning model cannot invent
data
but like lane changing how do you think
we get the lane changing
how do you think we ground truth that
right just another deep learning model
um we have uh sort of path
and i can show you i was writing loss
functions today in pi charts i can show
you the loss function
um
xx tools
so here uh this is the loss function
we're using
um so if we look
in i
think it's in model oh my god
why do you think the action space needs
to be discreet um
oh should i play my chrome chrome is out
of date don't know
uh why do we switch from tensorflow to
pie torch because pie torch
sucks
now where's uh i think it's some train
that's not in trains super combo
yeah there we go so if you look here um
we have plan mhpn equals five meaning
that it's actually outputting
five possible plants
for the car
uh lift level five has a new kaggle
challenge
let's let's let's see what their kaggle
challenge is
oh it's 3d object detection
is this is this the one
god
3d object detection not something
anybody needs you think you're detecting
3g
objects you're not you're definitely oh
we gotta
we got to make the thing reason using
this stuff because otherwise how can we
prove that it's good
you know you can't prove that it's good
but how do you prove that humans are
good
you can't yeah who's writing the cone
detector got to make sure you got a 3d
model for that cone
um
that's the old one what's the new one
did they did they give up on this stuff
do they give up on 3d object detection
what's the new one called
you think corporate espionage could ever
be a real concern for me
dude i tell you guys everything
you know you want to be a spy you just
got to uh watch the streams
they're concerned about corporate
espionage
why they were also on which ends
they were no no no no that someone's
going to come corporate espionage
us they're also i mean that'd be
delightful
they're also very uh
concerned about the single camera
single camera well they say you can't
solve self-driving cars with a single
camera
how can you solve social media i mean
not with a single camera apparently
we're only doing single camera forever
yo guys we're buying lidars all right
luminar man luminar get your specs here
did you talk about that yo my friend
texted me this morning he's like
have you considered a spec yeah
no no no my friend from home he's always
financed um
i think we should do his back solve it
with half a camera yeah now we're
talking
no no a man with one eye can drive
twitch did not give me a partnership so
i stream on youtube
now oh you're on youtube yeah
twitch didn't give me my partnership
deal did they at least formally reject
you no they did not
they just ignored you i'm i'm i'm in um
i'm in twitch purgatory right now i
don't want to pull any strings
either twitch accepts me for who i am or
i stream on youtube
hey if it's good enough for doctor
disrespect it's good enough for me
no come on this isn't a twitch stream
this is an official comic ice stream i
showed them the data center
for our official channel yeah i showed
them the data center i showed them the
money [ __ ] talk on our official chat i
showed them the money we've been making
i showed them the 32 gpu pie torch
trainer it's incredible
i know no alex like this is this is it
we're in the home stretch level three in
three years
we're in the home stretch oh yeah just
combine music
guys can you drive a car from the eon
feed
what can you not do
no you can't why because you can't check
your blind spots well guess what
the hyundai sonata 2020 limited has
blind spot sensors should we take them
on a drive this week
uh yeah maybe i'm gonna drive a long
time
no we haven't what if what if it throws
a model lag error
we're fixing it i'm doing that we're
fixing it
um we gotta we gotta complain more
we gotta be more you know the model like
ever is bad the out of focus hours
when you take when you take one this
week or friday
yeah we're fixing the door what else are
they complaining about i'm on it
best car for open pilot corolla probably
still when is the sonata gonna be the
best
uh they want to see you because there's
a physical there they're
like they don't have any pants on
they're like who's the other person
speaking
you just pull a chair over you're good
um
i like my i like my identity uh alex
wants your anonymity
uh you tried your challenge to get into
the company it's pretty hard but you
have an idea yeah and the channel is
pretty hard no it's not too hard
i've been sending out to a lot of people
uh we we met on linkedin
searching for opportunities in business
uh
please stop messaging me on linkedin
some of the worst parts about working
here
the linkedin's yo yo yeah no the
linkedin spam really
um so look
come work here and solve uh self-driving
cars
for real uh you know with like deep
learning
not with well i gotta draw a 3d box
around my objects
and then i will gather all the boxes
together and then i gotta make fun of
everyone else's technique
because i don't know what else to do
you're gonna get more boxes right you're
gonna get boxes
and then someone's eventually going to
realize guys we can use the lidar for
more than localization
look it can help bake boxes
flatter's worth a lot of money
[Laughter]
guys i'm calling it now spax are the new
icos
no they really are you nailed it yeah
um less risk
when launched the common token on
uniswap yeah
all right i see what dreams are over we
need to be able to map
all the cones in the world in real time
you need to know the dimensions of the
cone the 3d
spatial position of the cone we're
hiring a person
it's like like i say it is a joke but
like there's really guys doing that you
know
you know let's pour one out for the cone
people
can i get the thing the stick
oh you found the stick well we lost um
keyboards
wish i was two years in the future i
wish you were two years in the future
tesla has cone models i don't even know
what a baller it is
but you know who probably does know what
a ball it is the open pilot vision model
because he was trained end to end on
[ __ ] tons of data
um it's like doing it the hard way on
purpose you mean with the boxes or with
the end to end
i mean yeah there's some things that are
hard about the end to end it involves a
lot more like
thinking and debugging than just like
you know boxes can be done by very
mediocre software engineers
we could take they want to see the what
are they always like the dashboards oh
you guys want to see dashboards
ballard is a pole
uh what do you want to see on the
dashboards
oh we'll tell you stats okay so um our
total miles
ever is 29 million
our open pilot models miles is 25.8
million
they've grown tremendously in the last
year
here's where around the world people are
driving right now
you see some over here in asia some here
in europe
you got you got a few guys over in the
middle east
no users in africa and we have no users
in that
we have brazilian users i wonder where
they are let's zoom in on them
nope oh wait no no they're right there i
can see them here on the route map
oh you can yeah they're right down there
yeah
this is like the density map of comma
um so i hope that
the uptrend in the deviations is fake
this is us measuring the average
deviations of
how much uh the model and controls
aren't listening to each other uh here's
our
devices we have like
1500 daily active users
almost 2500 weekly active users
yeah and a lot of miles like just six
months ago
we had 18 million miles it's amazing
it's like 50 percent
growth right oh here's the four so
colorful
yeah who's got forks dragon pilots
kegman bagiver
shane um
uh do we separate miles of right-hand
drive countries no we don't
um would you separate the model now has
a separate
has an input which says yo are you
driving on the right or the left
but yeah that's you're on your personal
stream you play geogasser
have i thought about targeting
government organizations
as potential customers that sounds
boring
okay you know what just for the haters
on youtube
we're gonna do this once we have
thousands of users
are making hundreds of thousands of
dollars every month
are profitable have the second largest
network of self-driving cars
why would we like go out and like seek
out new customers or seek out investors
or
change our business model you know who
should change their business model
everyone who doesn't have users
is losing millions of dollars every
month
right oh no no no no no but they're
putting boxes around cones that's that's
the right way to solve self-driving cars
um now don't worry don't worry don't
worry if your box strategy doesn't work
out
you can just do us back i think the
sentiment is that they want us to be
successful
what's that with the questions oh no
yeah yeah i'm sure i'm sure i'm not i'm
not hating on the youtube people so you
know
i've been doing this for so many years
now and like
no one listens people are why do you get
the sense of people not listening
takes too long it takes too long for
them to listen
i mean yeah zooks did get sold at a fire
sale i haven't heard it from cruz in a
long time
who's thought about buying zooks
if someone has too much money yo
yo yo yo yo yo i'm a blind guy i'm gonna
hire a blind guy to lead me around
[Laughter]
what do you think the next thing we're
gonna see from cruz is um
well they're gonna um
take the crew's origin and they're going
to put up polycarbonate shields between
the seat
and talk about how the cruise origin now
is uh corona viruses
that one cruise origin cost more than a
comma
oh yeah yeah yeah um
i don't think people fully comprehended
that
any big hardware in the next six months
we so
we we're now we have an official policy
now on hardware deprecation
all hardware that hasn't been sold
after it hasn't been sold for a year
it's deprecated in open pilot that's the
policy going forward
i think it's reasonable yeah
um so big hardware you mean comma twos
they already launched
big models on the other hand uh those
are coming soon to every comato uh zero
eight is gonna be
a really nice release
you gotta fix the model x if it's all
flex we are gonna fix
that it's all gonna be fixed for zero
eight we're coming out with the new
segnet model
finally comma 10k is gonna uh
can we do a shout out for the 10k people
um
a shout out yeah shout out to pj lau who
else who else let's let's let's do some
shout outs of the people who i've seen
contributing to comet tom
kamatanka of course p jalal has been our
great coordinator
of uh of comma 10k i see
cedric ske
um i see vacuum on here a whole bunch
let's look at closed pull requests
that's going to be a good one
cedric ske definitely specter 56
dr sleepless you guys are all improving
the future of open pilot
you know we wouldn't be able to we
wouldn't be to be able to to make the
data big oh
a thing that's already in the new models
it outputs four
lanes now and the edges of the road
guess what that's for
guess what that's for who knows who
knows why would i want
four lanes and the edges of the road
if my driving is end to end
could i explain the hd maps there we go
you guys know what's up
it's finally happening the trick to hd
maps
is you have to do the map making almost
entirely on the device and that's why we
have the localizer that's why the model
is going to output four lanes and road
edges
um and then the reduce is going to be
something cheap
because the reduce used to be so
expensive like we were doing all the
localization in the cloud and clouds are
really expensive
but getting people to buy the hardware
and then running it on their device now
that's a win
see it's a cloud but other people pay
you for it make sure to pay your comma
prime bill
[Music]
you don't only use your eyes to drive
you use the existing models of the world
yeah what do you think's inside
though the model you know what do you
think what do you think it's learning
right now
it's learning all about the world from
our 25 million miles of driving data
um the dude just asked that the common
two was suitable for tropical climates
where the heat issues i know there were
some issues this summer
uh they're going to be better next
summer as open pilot becomes more cpu
efficient we're going to do a slight
down clock on the cpu
um and then very happy about that i
think yeah yeah yeah the down cloth will
make a lot of people happy
it's running kind of at the edge
um because we ship we shipped also big
driver monitoring model
the driving monitor model is an
efficient net we quadrupled the pixels
when will common go ipo why do i want an
ipo i want to solve self-driving cars
distractions ipos sound expensive we're
a profitable
company we don't need to scam investment
banks out of money
so what's an ipo right sorry i might
want to work with investment banks in
the future i shouldn't say things about
them some investment banks have reached
out to us
oh investment banks uh
[Music]
there's autopilot work it'll work on
dirt roads do i ever re-watch your tech
crunch pitch was funny and insightful
yeah
that's all right um
stay private if you can we plan to stay
private
uh we don't want people telling us what
to do or trying to tell us what to do
why am i on adderall
no because george is not on adderall he
is on
hold on
[Laughter]
no we got uh we got going around the
office we got mates
are the dashboards public no
yeah yo yak check we have been we have
been on the yak check
the whole company yo check them out we
got a fridge full of them
come work here drink some yak jack do i
recommend adderall
no follow your doctor i'm not a doctor
i'm a self-driving car guy
can you have check sponsor us yo yak
check if you want to sponsor us
seriously we'll chill for you man
i'll put an ad on comma i'll put it out
on the website
um you missed the server tour yeah
you can watch it later come watch you
later
i understand not just eyes but what i
see is interpreted in full details you
mean with your visual cortex
your comma two has one of those
yeah what kind of question is that um
boo dad on the comma two list of people
you hate
savage um
you guys missed the office tour uh
self-driving horses
we give a lot of office stores we do
merge plug
do you even have merch anymore new merch
is coming soon oh the new merch is
coming soon
tm all right all right hoodies for the
fall
um not gonna be cheap though
oh yeah yo i just remembered it because
i posted in discord
if you have comma prime and you didn't
sign up for the trial and you're like oh
wow
nobody remembered to cut off my service
i'm coming for you
i got 430 something sim cards they're
about to get deactivated
by the way if you want to come work here
and write a cron job to do the
deactivation script automatically uh
full stack engineer infrastructure
engineer
react if you went to boot camps probably
not
no one who's been to a boot camp yeah i
know it's sad
um
what do sres really do everyone here is
expected to code everyone's here is
expected to be on call when their code
breaks something
you just prefer good i don't care where
you came from
elon has rockets man i think i think
you see he got rockets you know you just
got to realize that all you got to do is
type in a different uh
well the space station or hmm
i don't know what do we want to hit with
the rocket you know
what's here icbms are rockets oh that's
sick bernie what one does have side
questions
you guys who do you think can drive
better
open pilot or you looking at the open
pilot camera
what are you going on lex friedman oh
like streaming part two it was discussed
i don't know am i a part two guy
i think elon's a part part two guy he
was a part two guy i think you're gonna
be a part two guy
maybe
you should do it again i agree i think
we have
something uh after the thing next year
okay good thing yeah whatever you want
thing no no no no no i don't care if
you're see
the problem with 2d boxes weren't that
they were 2d the problem is that they
were boxes
and a lot of companies like they put 2d
boxes around things and then they're
like
if only the boxes for 3d or self-driving
cars would work
they won't work better my
the reason follow-up was good yeah it
was different it was really different
but i thought it was good too
yeah i mean you know it was 2017. we
were hyping everything man we were
hyping brave we were hyping every every
every [ __ ] coin
and then you know by the time it's like
2020
well you know bitcoin and ethereum bros
so what's the next big thing for this
four cameras
i mean obviously you gotta be otherwise
how would people know you're rich
you don't have you know like show show
yeah
see look people know she's rich because
she's got three cameras
yeah oh uh
they're complaining about the sugar in
the mates look i told the team there's
too much sugar but you know
those young metabolisms are still good
it's at least oh look the caffeine's
organic
[Laughter]
um oh my god you can't drink this george
it has 33 grams of sugar in it do you
have one of these today
yeah it's disgusting
i mean drink your yerba mate it's a good
amount of grams
no i would i would appreciate 66
of your daily total value is this why
did you want dinner
no i already got dinner i went to i went
to crosstalk
does it need the uh sugar
no ah yo you guys make us
a costume we would like a costume how
many what quantity do we have to order
to get a custom yak check
wait red ball has triple wait how much
sugar and red bull
[Music]
this is 34. wait but this can
it's a lot bigger than that it is 16
ounces am i right
15.5 ah a red bull can
is 12 ounces
reusable rockets all right guys i think
we're good yeah thank you all for
watching the stream um
get ready to see the solution to
self-driving cars become obvious in the
next year become implemented in the next
one or two
uh if people want to come be our janitor
like we do need people we don't though
we don't see that's the problem with all
of those people
is they're going to require way too much
effort to manage
i don't know cutting thermal pads is not
very hard oh you'd be surprised
you know not everybody puts the boxes
together in the right orient
[Music]
all right guys thank you for watching uh
big models coming soon open pilot 0.8
hiring a com air
uh work authorized person to be our
navigation designer
we do the mean later yeah we're doing
the the vce logits
uh what do you mean outside
looking forward to the side cameras jump
in the discord just a question
if we were to sell the commission camera
how much would you pay for it
yeah that's a reasonable question yeah
well everyone goes quiet yeah how much
a lot all right all right let's hear
some dollars 69
200. oh they're never getting side
cameras
oh 400 500 to a thousand all right now
you're getting closer yeah
you're 500 you're you're getting closer
that's on top of a comma two right
it was a special comma two with the side
the side camera edition
um 476 is it a 12k
camera 1080p
what do you guys think 1080p is that a
good is that a good number you're too
good to know
7 20. um no all right
did you show comment you're up 19.99 now
we're talking that's a good price for
side cameras
um we also have an office in europe i'm
not allowed to go there right now
but some of you all are if you're
interested in a job on the openpilot
team
uh software engineers they're hiring out
at comma europe
uh software engineers that 1999 price
you know that's that's
that's that's a price i can get behind
if there's ever side cameras that's how
much they're gonna cost
at least at least yeah
2020 wow that's a better price
um whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa cameras don't cost 20 dollars
you got to get a lens for that camera
too
i think yeah at least 30 dollars 30
dollars
[Music]
uh
yup yup yup stocks are the same in the
eu
we open the door um
you guys it's not just the camera you're
buying the
the the the work that goes into putting
the camera
on the comma two you know the duct
taping the gluing right that's
flavor that's labor you know minimum
wage in california is like 15 bucks
12. 12. in addition to a comatose do you
mean 22
um
subscription model that's why we have a
firm
ghost on here no we control ghost uh the
frame rate's
20 fps look man if some company says
well we got space age safety and we
don't test on cars i mean you know you
can decide how seriously
they're charging a massive install fee
well what's the install
i think 3 500 bucks wow we're charging
way too little you guys i'm off just to
install uh no no ml in eu
only only open pilot um
wow and they're saying it could even be
more wow
all i'm hearing is that i should go into
shopify right now and raise the price of
the comma too
should we get the dice out
you're in here somewhere yeah who
remembers the good old days of rolling
the dice
why are those so good all day that could
be today two cameras buy two comma two
see
all right all right i can't i can't i
can't wait i can't wait
um
until
i know 2020 all included
that's not all included yeah by horns
too
i would love to access what more access
to can buses
what what do you think that the cameras
about the truck have to do
oh the f-150 yeah i thought about buying
an f-150 because i want to see if i'm a
pickup truck guy
and then i was like all right we're
going to pour it and pile up the f-150
but then i remember that it's a ford and
we didn't do it
so we would take another carport person
hd maps you guys know what's happening
oh yeah yeah we'd hire a cardboard
person you know what's happening next
year though with the hd maps guys
navigation key part of the road map
shout out to the chewing eyes club
um well com ever support the model 3 no
does android support ios
what kind of question is that yeah
um
yeah all right guys
thank you all for watching why do we
need hd maps for navigation
lane changes the problem with uh
so if you have most navigation routing
you have to know in advance when you
want to do the lane changes
you might be able to do it without it
but um
if you really want to get to level three
like there's a certain kind of hd map
that plays a role
it's not a role that's used for uh i
mean it's used for navigation
it's not used for precise localization
and driving um i think we're going to
use map box
at least kind of to start to tell you
someone brought in today
alternative solution wait who
oh they trying to sell me some solution
it's correct someone from openpilot
reached out to them you seen it
what all i know is if someone's trying
to sell it to you it's crap because they
can hire a sales guy
and not hire an engineer who's actually
going to make it good
it's not fun when you're not on twitch
you can't just go into your browser and
look at stuff
yeah that's true i don't like it it's
just watching me yeah
well fish should make me a partner um
no i want any government money guys it
comes with strings attached
we're talking about government you're
talking about government money yeah it
comes with strings attached before you
know what you're filling out
you're filling out some like environment
and like you know how many like
you know americans did you hire or
something you know like
you're opening an office in europe you
took government money you can't do that
see there's just like rules then um how
would the model interact with hd maps
you guys will say uh how would
think about it like this we're going to
get a camera
and we're going to get a waze and we're
going to point the camera
at the waves except it's hd ways and the
camera is virtual
like that
very clear thanks for watching the
stream hiring.com.ai or something
what coming to that jobs yes yes i'm
talking about hiring
comma dot ai perfect bye